I think there is going to be some
Republicans who say well I didn't like
Trump but I can put up with it there
will be Democrats who say I wish there
was a younger candidate but it's Biden
that's fine that's already been
happening a little bit but there's a big
chair of the country uh I think it'd be
bigger than 2016 that say I just can't
believe these are my choices and that's
going to be a lot of democratic strategy
is that's right then you just stick it
out with buying these are your choices
wait it out like if we beat Trump again
then you don't have to worry about them
in the future uh not in a very inspiring
campaign but not every campaign is
inspiring it let's say that Joe decides
to uh or not decides to either decides
or you know has a decided Forum where
it's like okay it's next march and he's
got a health problem uh you know and
people looking up saying oh snap so the
DNC
um Jamie Harrison right now
um so the the DNC has already come out
and said not having primary debates like
RFK Marion Williamson you know not not
legitimate tough luck uh essentially
um those debates that they existed would
be happening later this summer like this
year so by next march it would already
have been like essentially a debate free
season
um there might have been some states
voting and then Joe uh gets the votes
wins let's say in the current world but
then he has a health problem and Jamie
Harrison the DNC are like oh snap like
we can't run Joe in the general look it
would have to be led by the Vice
President and that's one even stranger I
mean the the fact of a 80 year old
president being being in a discussion of
whether he's too old is is not it's new
but it's it's you explain to somebody uh
from Mars they'll say well that makes
sense I don't know well I guess a year
has passed differently on Mars but then
we get the gist they were translated
into Martian years it'd be like hey
that's old but the uh the that's the
part that's the most vexing for
Democrats is that Kamala Harris uh the
first female vice president in history
no one's ever made it this far
um would would be the first female
president if you know it was not made
and wins and the conversation in in
Elite Democratic circles uh and in I
think the county party level is oh we're
just don't think that she could win so
we need to we need to think of something
else you can't just ignore the vice
president Kamal Harris if something were
to happen with Biden uh she would be
that is that is the vice president's
role she would be the error parent I
think it'd be a discussion of
um I I don't think the party you you
could game out fun scenarios I don't
think it's just possible it the realm of
the reality we work in
um for the party to say we had a meeting
and and because uh vice president is
polling kind of badly we replacing her
with somebody else who pulls better I
don't think they could it would be it
would be Harris and there'd be a DNC
vote over uh the vice presidential
candidate a lot of horse trading there
that would be difficult that'd be a
controversy who even gets it it's an
ugly situation I think it'd be
impossible I think it'd be impossible to
just not nominate Kamal Harrison that
would be a crisis that I don't know how
party would would um would bounce back
and win the election now
on paper like all this sounds crazy
because on paper you could say well
there's some there's some Democrats who
pull really well grouchy Whitman is
really popular
um other people with crossover repeal
Josh Shapiro the governor they do have a
bench of people that if you ask a
democratic strategist they'll tell you
oh can't wait for them to run for
president 2028 but they don't get that
choice because Joe Biden's president
Kamala Harris is Vice President I think
the party is just in a bind and these
the easiest path to this is to Winning
is Joe Biden becoming more popular and
Kamala Harris becoming more popular
through various decisions they make uh
and the economy going well it is it is a
very tough road I think I've not yes
Donald Trump had issues going into the
2020 election but this is the the
toughest set of of just facts for an
incumbent president facing re-election
that I think I've seen I've been alive
41 years definitely the hardest
60-something percent of Voters saying
they just don't think the person can do
the job anymore that is new and weird
well we all know that the voters uh vote
at the top of the ticket and I'm going
to say to you even though you're saying
and you know like a lot of people say
what you're saying is like look they
can't just bypass Kamala but to the
average American they're like Kamala
like President Kamala I'm not pumped
about I wasn't pumped about Veep Kamala
like this President Kamala thing and
polling bears that out uh I'm going to
say I think Kamala loses to Trump you
know I can see the case where Joe can
eek it out uh you know like that that
thing's pretty close but I think Kamala
just loses that that race Head to Head
it's one reason why I thought that look
just like have a genuine process if
Kamala can emerge
um from a competitive primary Victorious
then you know fantastic she would one
over a lot of people
but you know I think going with her as
the top of the ticket because you know
you're afraid of
um alienating uh you know like the the
Democrats African-American base uh like
I just think that would lead to uh a
loss in November I I think there's a
couple situations one is is what happens
in 2028 I think you're right um but
um public opinion is movable
um but I I I I I don't want to do even
this is very fun speculation but I just
the one thing I think I thought about
that is not obvious is yeah what would
happen because this happens at the lower
level there's somebody who's lieutenant
governor and nobody thinks lieutenant
governor could win on their own or
handle the job they come into the job
people say well I'm I have complicated
feelings about how the governor resigned
or the governor died or the governor
took another job but this lieutenant
governor is really putting it together
in a way that surprises me I think there
is a chance for a honeymoon depending
how this goes but um but no I mean the
the par the party is uh has a front
runner in Waiting who most of the party
thinks cannot win that's the just that's
the gist of it and I think they would
need to just change the facts about
Kamala Harris and she would need to
change people's Impressions and the
facts any about her for her to be a
competitive candidate that's really
tough it's much more fun for Democrats
to say gosh couldn't we just do a draft
and find like a governor he's really
good at this
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang up new
guest thank you